Charles Barkley had a busy weekend
watching people play golf some really
really good golf and some really really
bad golf Charles gonna relate to the
latter part of that as Charles Jones
just saw in the program good morning
Charles how are you my man I'm doing
great thanks for having me did you get
to play any golf while you were I know
you played one hole but did you play any
golf when you were down there I did I
played with Justin Verlander
great Justin Verlander and the great
Dustin Johnson on Saturday it was
awesome and Joe Smith the pitcher who's
married to out of the force we had a
really good time I played better sadder
than ideas sunny that was ironic about
the whole thing how much pressure did
you feel playing that one hole well I
just choked a tremendous pressure I was
the only person there and a TV crew and
I just choked I hit an awful actually
the drive is the only bad shot I hit but
I just choked on the pressure plain and
simple you know when you start to look
at these guys out there I thought Tiger
looked unbelievable like that was sort
of lost in everything because we were
focused on Brady having problems he had
a couple of really good shots the
trash-talking tiger looked awesome
I think out of all of this - Chuck what
did you make of Tigers performance well
first of all you to me when he's healthy
always looks Austin he played great
Sunday he was very relaxed you know I
thought the key to the whole thing was
how relaxed the players were and how
much fun they had you know and I think
let me just say this Dan if I'm the PGA
Tour this is my piece advice to them
we're not gonna have fans they should
make the players I really believe that
that's just my two cents for the PGA
Tour I really think they should consider
if you're not gonna have fans you can to
just have guys playing golf and
announcers talking I think if they're
gonna be successful in our great ratings
I'm wanting that very register we need
golf
we need sports but I think they should
consider having Mike and the players
there were a couple of great moments
with
in Tom Brady here's Brady hitting that
great shot from the fairway and had this
to say to Charles
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Wow that's pretty good stuff Charles I
thought it was awesome you know you know
I you know I got a lot of love for Tom
Brady are we cities to go a pro football
you know to have the greatest golfer
ever and the greatest football player
out there and Peyton Manning he's one of
the three or four best quarterbacks ever
and you got feel who's one of the three
or four best golfers ever man it was
just awesome being out there and I get
those guys number one a lot of credit
but playing in a two ritual downpour I
mean the weather was awful but also man
they raised a lot of money a lot of
money so but I got to get those guys
traded man because it never stopped
raining the whole day basically who was
the best trash talker out there Oh
Peyton you know Peyton was because paid
was taking shots at his home boys back
home that's what I love the most about
it you know a few of you a friend of
panes and he's saying your name on
national TV to one guy that he picked up
about 30 pounds during the quarantine I
mean I thought that was hilarious but I
felt Peyton was awesome they all were
great but Peyton was the best and then
Tom I haven't been around Tom that much
but I thought he relaxed and had a good
time I think that was perfect that
shotty hit the shut me up
but I'll tell you what man I got a lot
of love and I do you know Dan that dude
hit balls like seven hours on Saturday
you know guys would tell me I say you
know chunk but on the range for like
seven hours and there's about this damn
Sunday morning he got up early and
played 18 holes and then he did a
complete well
he did a workout in the parking lot the
guy says man Tom Tom Brady is an animal
I'm like what you talking about he says
he's out there doing wind sprints and
things in the parking lot and I'm like
that doesn't that was impressive to me I
like say the hit balls for seven hours
on Saturday play 18 and being do a
football workout on Sunday morning
that was incredible I got there you got
to respect that dude how much money did
this weekend cost you we didn't play for
money we just played for pride well no
you put up your put of 50 you o52 brady
his charity right
no he mr. green oh I thought mr. green
oh okay
oh that's right you said maybe you could
keep it on the planet or something when
you hit the green he wasn't even close
to the green was their 19th hole not
after the match not after the match but
that was a 19th hole that was a 1
through 18 hole on Saturday with Justin
Dustin and Joe Smith oh you had some
beverages with those guys yes I'm
calling transfusion but if I was gonna
do this again which I'm sure the PGA
Tour and TNT would want to do this again
who would you have now well I read well
Drew Brees and Sergio Garcia want to
join would Jordan do this I don't know
that question I think he should you know
you know listen you know it's
interesting that Tom Brady can do
nothing paid manic and do nothing to
hurt their reputation but I look at the
big picture we raised 20 million dollars
for people who really needed it if you
put Michael and another pro do Bri
and another pearl Sergio it doesn't want
to challenge the winner oh I think
Russell Wilson challenged the winner so
if you could get ten teams I guarantee
you you could probably wait I mean at
least wanted million dollars yeah I mean
that that was awesome
would you be playing if they asked me to
play dude I'm not gonna listen as long
as I can drink and smoke when I play
golf I'm good have some drinks and some
stogies I'm not gonna be overly
concerned about how good a bad I played
I mean I don't think Tom Brady lost a
lot of sleep but he was struggling on
the front nine I mean but man I'm always
we raised a lot of money for feeding
America and all those other charities
man and they really struggling and
anything we can do to help those god man
it's worth it when did you realize Brady
split his pants
[Laughter]
we're talking to Charles Barkley the
Hall of Famer TNT inside the NBA analyst
I guess we're having basketball what do
you think of this format of having the
top 16 playoff teams and they're not
gonna have East Coast West Coast or
Eastern Conference Western Conference
well I'm pretty sure we're going to play
I'll just talk until my boss says I
don't think they know exactly how
they're gonna do it but they're going to
play I'm 100% sure of that I don't know
if they've finalized a final format yet
but they're going to play basketball for
sure I'm 100% sure that it's going to be
interesting you know like I say I'm
still concerned about the virus I'm
still really concerned about the
legitimacy of the playoffs and what I
mean by that Danny
what do we do if one of the great
players get to virus I don't I just
worry about that like I don't this is
not anybody in particular say Yanis
LeBron Anthony Davis
Russell Westbrook James Harden Joelle
and being one of these great players get
to Bowers do you take their whole you
got to take their whole team out the
tournament don't you I mean you can't
take one player you know they've been
exposed to other players so do those
guys or fit around in the playoffs we
can't start the playoffs being stopped
the playoffs so that that kind of stuff
concerns me
I don't believe what you know Shaq said
there would be an asterisk I don't
believe that but I will say if the best
players get to Bauer's aren't able to
play then I think you'll have an
asterisk asterisk well I think the
asterisk is only going to apply if
LeBron James wins the title Chuck I mean
let's be honest that that just feels
like people are waiting if LeBron wins
it to say but this doesn't really count
as a full championship or if you honest
wins it or Kawhi wins that I don't think
there's gonna be any outrage it would
just be if LeBron James won you know
there's haters out there with LeBron
Chuck and that that's what's going on
listen there's I've been other
championship that had won by showing
season strike seasons you know even last
year Toronto though you not count them
with champion goes KB and clear out no
no I wouldn't I wouldn't apply an
asterisk to that nobody did that with
San Antonio in 1999 when they won no
one's ever said no I said they'll be
there for LeBron nobody else no I don't
believe that I don't think that's LeBron
hate out there I think that these idiots
and fools on television have had nothing
to talk about for the last two months
but those are the guys who are gonna be
bringing this up this is writer Skip
Bayless misses
get Bayliss his wheelhouse and you know
that I don't pay that dude with any
attention I don't pay that dude any
attention whoever wins it it's gonna
listen under these circumstances you've
got to give them bonus points we've
never seen anything like this in our
lifetime I wish all the nurses and first
responders great health number one and
I'll shout out to all the people who
served in the war for memorial date
thank you for your service and all that
other great stuff but now I mean there's
gonna be a couple foods on television
talk about it but whoever wins it like I
say the only way I think you can put an
asteroid by Dan if let's say some of the
great players don't play yeah and that
to me is fair yes we have a couple of
stars that get the virus and first of
all like I say you got to take their
whole team out to tournament you can't
take one player out to tournament and if
a bad team gets a skate because of one
of the great players on the team was
able to play and I think you can't put
an asterisk by it yeah I'm with you on
that I understand that and I wouldn't
put an asterisk by any of these teams or
any of these players because it's a
level playing field everybody's had to
sort of deal with the same thing but the
NBA gets one chance and you got to do it
right because as you said if somebody
test positive now all of a sudden you
may be a house of cards where you just
have to close up shop here
yeah like I say it's a really scary
thing you know
hockey's gonna come back baseball's
gonna come back so deep we're gonna be
kind of you know everybody's gonna be
looking at us especially college
football and pro football there's gonna
be watching us with a fine-tooth comb
seeing how we react to every situation
you know it you know I told you guys man
I'm I don't know if we should play
because I don't know how safe because I
would hate to see number one any of my
players get sick but I would hate to see
a guy
get his wife or girlfriend his kids sick
I think that would be catastrophic for
sports and the NBA
I just wish everybody great health but
man we're going to play it is going to
be a crapshoot it's great to visit with
he was a lot of fun I thought Justin
Thomas was a star too I thought his on
the course you know analysis was a lot
of fun with the match as well well I
thought he was a great he was great he
got heat further he's a great kid he's a
great cop got a great personality the
bottom line though is he sucks out the
codes are you coachable
are you coachable hey listen
he had me striping it on it was a great
coaching practice yeah but I've seen you
on the range and you could you're okay
on the range something happens when you
walk from the range you know over to the
first team you know listen I still even
though I didn't play that whole great I
only hit one bad shot my drive so I had
to come you don't have to find a
positive- I got to find a way to get off
the tee but think about it I had two
good shots to get on the green I
shouldn't and I should never three-putt
but I was encouraged after my double
bogey there keep your head up all right
Thank You brothers hey man you guys be
safe everybody be safe and shout out to
all the hospitality workers that they
were struggling bless y'all Thank You
Charles such Charles Barkley
hall-of-famer part-time golfer